[Music]
i am sure of it
inglis laid down his knife and fork he
stared round and round the small
apartment in a manner which was
distinctly strange
my wife caught him up she laid down her
knife and fork
you're sure of what inglis seemed
disturbed
he appeared unwilling to give a direct
answer
perhaps after all it's only a
coincidence
but violet insisted what is a
coincidence
inglis addressed himself to me the fact
is millen
directly i came on board i thought i had
seen this boat
before but i thought you said that you
had never heard of the water lily
nor have i the truth is that when i knew
it
it wasn't the water lily i don't
understand
they must have changed the name unless i
am very much mistaken this
this used to be the self the self
you don't mean to say that you've never
heard of the self
english asked this question in a tone of
voice which was peculiar
my dear fellow i'm not a river ren
authority
i'm not acquainted with every houseboat
between richmond and oxford
it was only at your special
recommendation that i took the water
lily
excuse me milan i advised a houseboat i
didn't specify the water lily
but asked my wife what was the matter
with the self that she should soon
mysteriously have become the water lily
inglis fenced with this question in a
manner which seemed to suggest a state
of mental confusion
of course millen i know that that sort
of thing would not have the slightest
influence on you
it is only people of a very different
sort who would allow it to have any
effect on them
then after all i may be wrong and in any
case i don't see that it matters
mr inglis are you suggesting that the
self was haunted
haunted inglis started i never dropped a
hint about it's being haunted
so far as i remember i never heard a
word of anything of the kind
violet placed her knife and fork
together on her plate she folded her
hands upon her lap
mr inglis there is a mystery will you
let this mystery unfold
didn't you really ever hear about the
self two years ago
two years ago we were out of england so
you were
perhaps that explains it you understand
this may not be the self i may be wrong
though i don't think i
am inglis glanced uncomfortably at the
chair on which he was sitting
why i believe this is the very chair on
which i sat
i remember noticing what a queer shape
it was
it was rather an odd-shaped chair for
that matter
all the things on board were odd then
have you been on board this boat before
yes inglis positively shuttered
i was once if it is the self that is
he thrust his hands into his trouser
pockets he leaned back in his chair
a curious look came into his face it is
the self i'll swear to it
it all comes back to me what an
extraordinary coincidence
one might almost think there was
something supernatural in the thing
his manner fairly roused me i wish you
would stop speaking in brittles
and tell us what you were driving at he
became preeter naturally solemn
millen i'm afraid i've made rather an
ass of myself
i ought to have held my tongue but the
coincidence is such a strange one that
it took me unawares
and since i have said so much i suppose
i may as well say more
after dinner i will tell you all there
is to tell i don't think it's a story
which mrs millen would like to listen to
violet's face was a study i don't
understand you mr inglis
because you were quite well aware it is
a principle of mine that what is good
for a husband to hear
is good for a wife come don't be silly
let us hear what the fuss is about i
dare say it's about nothing after all
you think so well mrs millen you shall
hear
he carefully wiped his mustache he began
two years ago there was a houseboat on
the river called the self
it belonged to a man named hambro he
lent it to a lady and a gentleman
she was rather a pretty woman with a lot
of fluffy golden hair
he was a quiet unassuming looking man
who looked as though he had something to
do with horses
i made their acquaintance on the river
one evening he asked me on board to dine
i sat as i believe on this very chair at
this very table
three days afterwards they disappeared
well i asked inglis had paused
so far as i know he has never been seen
or heard of since
and the lady some of us were getting up
a picnic
we wanted them to come with us we
couldn't quite make out their sudden
disappearance
so two days after we had missed them i
and another man tried to route them out
i looked through the window i saw
something lying on the floor
jarvis i whispered i believe that mrs
bush is lying on the floor
dead drunk she can't have been drunk two
days
he said he came to my side why
she's in her night dress this is very
queer
english i wonder if the door is locked
it wasn't
we opened it and went inside inglis
emptied his glass of wine
the woman we had known as mrs bush lay
in her night dress
dead upon the floor she had been stabbed
to the heart
she was lying just about where mrs
millen is sitting now
mr inglis violet rose suddenly
there is reason to believe that from one
point of view the woman was no better
than she ought to have been
that is the story but i confess
it was not at all the story i had
expected it was going to be
i did not altogether like it who killed
her
that is the question there was no direct
evidence to show
no weapon was discovered the man we had
known as bush had vanished as it seemed
off the face of the earth
he had not left so much as a pocket
handkerchief behind him
everything both of his and hers had gone
it turned out that nobody knew anything
at all about him
they had no servant what meals they had
on board were sent in from the hotel
hambro had advertised the self
bush had replied to the advertisement he
had paid the rent in advance
and hambro had asked no questions
and what became of the sylph she also
vanished
she had become a little too notorious
one doesn't fancy living on board a
houseboat on which a murder has been
committed
one is at two close quarters i suppose
hambro
sold her for what he could get and the
purchaser painted her
and re-christened her the water lily but
are you sure this is the self
as sure as that i am sitting here it is
impossible that i could be mistaken
i still seem to see that woman lying
dead just about where mrs millen is
standing now
mr inglis violet was standing up
she moved away towards me inglis left
soon afterwards
he did not seem to care to stop he had
scarcely eaten any dinner
in fact that was the case with all of us
mason had exerted herself to prepare a
decent meal in her cramped little
kitchen
and we had been so ungrateful as not
even to reach the end of her bill of
fare
when english had gone she appeared in
her bonnet and cloak we supposed that
very naturally she had taken umbrage
if you please ma'am i'm going mason what
do you mean
i couldn't think of stopping in no place
in which murder was committed
least of all a houseboat not to mention
that last night i heard ghosts
if ever anyone heard them yet mason
don't be absurd
i thought you had more sense all i can
say is ma'am
that last night as i lay awake listening
to the splashing of the water
all at once i heard in here the sound of
quarreling i couldn't make it out
i thought that you and the master was
having words yet it didn't sound like
your voices
besides you went on awful still i didn't
like to say nothing because it might
have been
and it wasn't my place to say that i had
heard but now i know that it was ghosts
she went she was not to be persuaded to
stay any more than english
she did not even stay to clear the table
i have seldom seen a woman in a greater
hurry
as for wages there was not a hint of
them
stayed elderly self-possessed female
though she was
she seemed to be in a perfect panic of
fear nothing would satisfy her but that
she should with the greatest possible
expedition
shake from her feet the dust of the
water lily
when we were quit of her i looked at
violet and violet looked at me
i laughed i will not go so far as to say
that i laughed genially
still i laughed we seemed to be in for a
pleasant river holiday
eric let us get outside we went on deck
the sun had already set there was no
moon
but there was a cloudless sky the air
was langrious and heavy
boats were stealing over the waters
someone in the distance was playing a
banjo accompaniment while a clear
girlish voice was singing
the garden of sleep the other houseboats
were radiant with chinese lanterns
the water lily alone was still in shadow
we drew our deck chairs close together
violet's hand
stolen to mine eric do you know that
last night
i too heard voices you
i laughed again violet i couldn't make
it out at all
i was just going to wake you when they
were still
you were dreaming child inglis's story
confound him in his story has recalled
your dream to mind
i hope you don't wish to follow mason's
example and make a bolt of it
i have paid pretty stiffly for the honor
of being the water lily tenant for a
month
not to mention the fact of disarranging
all our plans
violet paused before she answered no
i don't think i want as you say to make
a bolt of it
indeed she nestled closer to my side
it is rather the other way i should like
to see it through
i have sometimes thought that i should
like to be with someone i can trust in a
situation such as this
perhaps we may be able to fathom the
mystery who knows
this tickled me i thought you had done
with romance
with one sort of romance i hope i shall
never have done
she pressed my hand she looked up archly
into my
face i knew it although we were in
shadow
with another sort of romance i may be
only just beginning
i have never yet had dealings with a
ghost
at first i could not make out what it
was that had roused me
then i felt violet's hand steel into
mine
her voice whispered in my ear eric
i turned over towards her on the pillow
be still
they're here i did as she bade me
i was still i heard no sound but the
lazy rippling of the river
who's here i asked when as i deemed i
had been silent long enough
shh i felt her finger pressed against my
lips
i was still again the silence was broken
in rather a peculiar manner
i don't think you quite understand me
the words were spoken in a man's voice
as it seemed to me close behind my back
i was so startled by the unexpected
presence of a third person
that i made as if to spring up in bed my
wife caught me by the arm
before i could remonstrate or shake off
her grasp
a woman's laughter rang through the
little cabin
it was too metallic to be agreeable and
a woman's voice replied
i understand you well enough don't you
make any error
there was a momentary pause you don't
understand me
fool the first four words were spoken
with a deliberation which meant
volumes while the final epithet came
with a sudden malignant ferocity which
took me aback
the speaker whoever he might be meant
mischief
i sprang up and out of bed what are you
doing here
i cried i addressed the inquiry
apparently to the vacant air
the moonlight flooded the little cabin
it showed clearly enough that it was
empty
my wife sat up in bed now
she observed you've done it done what
who was that speaking the voices
the voices what voices i'll voice them
where the dickens had they gone i moved
towards the cabin door
with the intention of pursuing my
inquiries further
violet's voice arrested me it is no use
you're going to look for them
they will not be found by searching the
speakers were mr and mrs bush
mr and mrs bush violet's voice dropped
to an awful whisper
the murderer and his victim i stared at
her in the moonlight
english's pleasant little story had
momentarily escaped my memory
suddenly roused from a dreamless slumber
i had not yet time to recall such
trivialities
now it all came back in a flash violet
i exclaimed have you gone mad they are
the voices which i heard last night
they are the voices which mason heard
now you have heard them
if you had kept still the mystery might
have been unraveled
the crime might have been re-enacted
before our eyes or at least within sound
of our ears
i sat down upon the ingenious piece of
furniture which did duty as a bed
i seem to have struck upon a novel phase
in my wife's character
it was not altogether a pleasing novelty
she spoke with a degree of judicial
calmness which under all the
circumstances
i did not altogether relish violet i
wish you wouldn't talk like that
it makes my blood run cold why should it
my dear eric i have heard you yourself
say that in the presence of the
seemingly mysterious
our attitude should be one of
passionless criticism
a mysterious crime has been committed in
this very chamber
i shivered surely it is our duty to
avail ourselves of any opportunities
which may offer
and which may enable us to probe it to
the bottom
i made no answer i examined the doors
they were locked and bolted there was no
sign that anyone had tampered with the
fastenings
i returned to bed as i was arranging
myself between the sheets
violet whispered in my ear perhaps if we
are perfectly quiet
they may come back again i am not a man
given to adjectives
but i felt adjectival then i was about
to explain
in language which would not have been
wanting in force that i had no desire
that they should come back again
when you had better give it to me
the words were spoken in a woman's voice
as it seemed within 12 inches of my back
the voice was not that of a lady i
should have said without hesitation
had i heard the voice under any other
circumstances that the speaker had been
born within the sound of beau bell's
had i it was a man's voice which put the
question
there was something about the tone in
which the speaker put it which reminded
one of the line in the people's ballad
it ain't exactly what he says it's the
nasty way he says it
the question was put in a very nasty way
indeed
yes my boy you had indeed
yes you may say indeed but if you don't
i'll tell you what i'll do
i'll spoil you and what my dear gertie
am i to understand by the mystic threat
of spoiling me
i'll go straight to your wife and i'll
tell her everything
oh you will will you there was a
movement of a chair
the male speaker was getting up yes i
will
there was a slight pause one could fancy
that the speakers were facing each other
one could picture the look of impudent
defiance upon the woman's countenance
the suggestion of coming storm upon that
of the man
it was the man's voice which broke the
silence
it is odd gertrude that you should have
chosen this evening to threaten me
because i myself had chosen this evening
i won't say to threaten
but to make a communication to you
give me a match the request came from
the woman
with pleasure i will give you anything
my dear gertrude within reason
there was another pause in the silence i
seemed to hear my wife holding her
breath
as i certainly was holding mine all at
once there came a sound of scratching
a flash of light it came so unexpectedly
and such was the extreme tension of my
nerves
that with a stifled exclamation i half
rose in bed
my wife pressed her hand against my lips
she held me down
she spoke and so attenuated a whisper
that it was only because all my senses
were so keenly on the alert that i heard
her
you goose he's only striking a match
he might have been but who she took
things for granted
i wanted to know the light continued
flickering to
and fro as a match does flicker i would
have given much to know who held it
or even what was its position in the
room
as luck had it my face was turned the
other way
my wife seemed to understand what was
passing in my mind
there's no one there she whispered no
one i presumed but the match
i took it for granted that was there
though i did not venture to inquire
i felt that i might not have such
perfect control over my voice
as my wife appeared to have while the
light continued to flicker
there came stealing into my nostrils i
sniffed the thing was unmistakable
the odor of tobacco the woman was
lighting a cigarette
i knew it was the woman because
presently there came this request from
the man
after you with the light my dear
i presume that the match was passed
immediately the smell of tobacco
redoubled
the man had lit a cigarette as well i
confess that i resented
silently but still strongly the idea of
two strangers
whether ghosts or anybody else smoking
uninvited in my cabin
the match went out the cigarettes were
lit
the man continued speaking the
communication my dear gertrude which i
intended to make to you
was this the time has come for us to
part
he paused possibly for an answer none
came
i need not enlarge on the reasons which
necessitate our parting
they exist pause again
then the woman what are you going to
give me
one of the reasons which necessitate our
parting a very strong reason
as you i am sure will be the first to
admit is that i have nothing left to
give you
so you say precisely so i say
and so i mean do you mean that you are
going to give me nothing
i mean my dear gertrude that i have
nothing to give you
you have left me nothing ba the sound
which issued from the lady's lips was
expressive of the most complete contempt
look here my boy you give me a hundred
sovereigns or i'll spoil you
pause again probably the gentleman was
thinking over the lady's observation
what benefit do you think you will do
yourself by what you call spoiling me
never mind about that i'll do it you
think i don't know all about you
but i do perhaps i'm not so soft as you
think
your wife's got some money if you
haven't suppose you go back and ask her
for some
you've treated me badly enough i don't
see why you shouldn't go and treat her
the same
she wouldn't make things warm for you if
she knew a few things i could tell her
not at all you give me a hundred
sovereigns or i tell you straight i'll
go right to your house and i'll tell her
all
oh no you won't won't i i say i will
oh no you won't i say i will
i've warned you that's all i'm not going
to stop here
talking stuff to you i'm going to bed
you can go and hang yourself for all i
care
there was a sound an indubitable sound
the sound of a pair of shoes being
thrown upon the floor
there were other sounds equally capable
of explanation
sounds which suggested i wish the
printer would put it in small type
that the lady was undressing undressing
too with scant regard to ceremony
garments were thrown off and tossed
higgledy-piggledy here and there
they appeared to be thrown with sublime
indifference
upon table chairs and floor i even felt
something a light upon the bed
some feminine garment perhaps which
although it fell by no means heavily
made me conscious as it fell of the most
curious sensation i had in all my life
till then experienced it seemed that the
lady
while she unroved continued smoking from
her next words it appeared that the
gentleman
also smoking stood and stared at her
don't stand staring at me like a gawk
i'm going to turn
in and i'm going to turn out
not as you suggested to hang myself but
to finish this cigarette upon the roof
perhaps when i return you will be in a
more equitable frame of mind
don't you flatter yourself what i say i
mean
a hundred sovereigns or i tell your wife
he laughed very softly
as though he was determined not to be
annoyed then we heard his footsteps as
he crossed the floor
the door opened then closed we heard him
ascend the steps
then with curious distinctness his
measured [ __ ] [ __ ]
as he moved to and fro upon the roof
in the cabin for a moment there was
silence
then the woman said with a curious
faltering in her voice
i'll do it i don't care what he says
there was a choking in her throat
he don't care for me a bit suddenly she
flung herself upon her knees beside the
bed
she pillowed her head and arms upon the
coverlet
i lay near the outer edge of the bed
which was a small one by the way
as i lay i felt the pressure of her
limbs
my sensations as i did i am unable to
describe
after a momentary interval there came
the sound of sobbing
i could feel the woman quivering with
the strength of her emotion
violet and i were speechless i do not
think that for the instant we could have
spoken
even had we tried the woman's presence
was so evident
her grief so real as she wept
disjointed words came from her i've
given
everything for him if he only cared for
me if he only did
all at once with a rapid movement she
sprang up
the removal of the pressure was
altogether unmistakable
i was conscious of her resting her hands
upon the coverlet to assist her to her
feet
i felt the little jerk then the
withdrawal of the hands
she choked back her sobs when she had
gained her feet
her tone was changed what a fool i am to
make a fuss
he don't care for me not that we heard
her snap her fingers in the air
he never did us women are always fools
we're all the same i'll go to bed
violet clutched my arm she whispered in
that attenuated fashion she seemed to
have caught the trick of
she's getting into bed we must get out
it certainly was a fact someone was
getting into bed
the bed clothes were moved not our bed
clothes but some
phantom coverings we heard them rustle
we were conscious of a current of air
across our faces
as someone caught them open and then
then someone stepped upon the bed let's
get out
gasped violet
she moved away from me she squeezed
herself against the side of the cabin
she withdrew her limbs from between the
sheets
as for me the person who had stepped
upon the bed had actually stepped upon
me
and that without seeming at all
conscious of my presence
someone sat down plump upon the sheet
beside me
that was enough i took advantage of my
lying on the edge of the bed to slip out
upon the floor
i might possess an unsuspected capacity
for undergoing strange experiences
but i drew the line at sleeping with a
ghost
the moonlight streamed across the room
as i stood
in something very like a state of nature
on the floor
i could clearly see violet cowering on
the further side of the bed
i could distinguish all her features
but when i looked upon the bed itself
there was nothing there
the moon's rays fell upon the pillow
they revealed its snowy whiteness
there seemed nothing else it could
reveal it was untenanted
and yet if one looked closely at it it
seemed to be indented
just as it might have been indented had
a human head been lying there
but about one thing there could be no
mistake whatever
my ears did not play me false i heard it
too distinctly
the sound made by a person who settles
himself between the sheets
and then the measured respiration of one
who composes himself to slumber
i remained there silent on her hands and
knees violet crept towards the foot of
the bed
when she had gained the floor she stole
on tiptoe to my side
i did not dare to step across her i felt
her as she nestled to me
give me a little shiver i could not do
it can you see her
what a fool i am as violet asked her
question there came this observation
from the person in the bed
who by the way i could not see there was
a long drawn sigh
what fools all we women are what fools
there was a sincerity of bitterness
about the tone which coming as it did
from an unseen speaker
one so near and yet so far had on one a
most
uncomfortable effect violet pressed
closer to my side
the woman in the bed turned over
overhead there still continued the
measured [ __ ] tramping of the man
we were conscious in some subtle way
that the woman lay listening to the
footsteps
they spoke more audibly to her ears even
than to ours
ali ali she repeated the name softly to
herself
with a degree of tenderness which was in
startling contrast to her previous
bitterness
i wish you had come to bed she was
silent
it was only the sound of her gentle
breathing her bitter mood had been but
transient
she was falling asleep with words of
tenderness upon her lips
above the footsteps ceased all was still
there was not even the murmur of the
waters the wife and i
side by side stood looking down upon
what seemed an empty bed
she's asleep said violet it seemed to me
she was
although i could not see her it seemed
to me she was
i could hear her breathing as softly as
a child
violet continued whispering how strange
eric what can it mean i muttered a reply
a problem for the psychical research
society
it seems just like a dream i wish it
were a dream
shh there's someone coming down the
stairs
there was at least if we could trust our
ears there was
apparently the man above had had enough
of solitude
we heard him move across the roof then
pause just by the steps
then descend them one by one it seemed
to us that in this step there was
something stealthy
that he was endeavoring not to arouse
attention to make as little noise as
possible
halfway down he paused at the foot he
paused again
he's listening outside the door it
almost seemed that he was
we stood and listened too let's get away
from the bed
my wife drew me with her at the opposite
end of the cabin was a sort of little
alcove
which was screened by a curtain and
behind which were hung one or two of our
garments which we were not actually
using
violet drew me within the shadow of this
alcove
i say drew me because offering no
resistance
i allowed myself to be completely
passive in her hands
the alcove was not large enough to hold
us
still the curtain acted as a partial
screen
the silence endured for some moments
then we heard without
a hand softly turning the handle of the
door
while i was wondering whether after all
i was not the victim of an attack of
indigestion
or whether i was about to witness an
attempt at affecting a burglaries entry
into a houseboat
a strange thing happened the strangest
thing that had happened yet
as i have already mentioned the moon's
rays flooded the cabin
this was owing to the fact that a long
narrow casement
which ran round the walls near the roof
of the cabin had been left open
for the sake of admitting air and
ventilation but save for the moonbeams
the cabin was unlighted
when however we heard the handle being
softly turned
a singular change occurred it was like
the transformation
scene in a theater the whole place all
at once was brilliantly illuminated
the moonbeams disappeared instead a
large swinging lamp was hanging from the
center of the cabin
so strong was the light which it shed
around that our eyes were dazzled
it was not our lamp we used small hand
lamps which stood upon the table
by its glare we saw that the whole cabin
was changed
for an instant we failed to clearly
realize and what the change consisted
then we understood it was a question of
decoration
the contents of the cabin for the most
part were the same
though they looked newer and the
positions of the various articles were
altered
but the panels of the cabin of the water
lily were painted blue and white
the panels of this cabin were colored
chocolate and gold
eric it's the self the suggestion
conveyed by my wife's whispered words
even if she spoke occurred to me
i understood where for english had
lained the difficulty of recognition
the two cabins were the same and yet
were not
it was just as though someone had
endeavored without spending much cash
to render one as much as possible unlike
the other
in this cabin there were many things
which were not ours
in fact so far as i can see there was
nothing which was ours
strange articles of costume were
scattered about the table was covered
with a curious litter
and on the ingenious article of
furniture which did duty as a bed
and which stood where our beds stood and
which indeed seemed to be our bed
there was someone sleeping as my
startled eyes traveled round this
amazing transformation
scene at last they reached the door
there they stayed
mechanically i shrank back nearer to the
wall
i felt my wife tighten her grasp upon my
hand
the door was open some few inches
through the aperture thus formed there
appeared a man
he seemed to be listening it was so
still that one could hear the gentle
breathing of the woman sleeping in the
bed
apparently satisfied he opened the door
sufficiently wide to admit of his
entering the cabin
my impression was that he could not fail
to perceive us
yet to all appearances he remained
entirely unconscious of our neighborhood
he was a man certainly under five feet
six in height
he was slight and build very dark with
face clean shaven
his face was long and narrow in dress
and bearing he seemed a gentleman
yet there was that about him which
immediately reminded me of what inglis
had said of the man
bush he looked as though he had
something to do with horses
he stood for some seconds in an attitude
of listening
so close to me that i had only to
stretch out my hand to take him by the
throat
i did not do it i don't know what
restrained me
i think more than anything it was the
feeling that these things which were
passing before me
must be passing in a dream his face was
turned away
he looked intently towards the sleeping
woman
after he had had enough of listening he
moved towards the bed
his step was soft and cat-like it was
absolutely noiseless
glancing down i perceived that he was
without boots or shoes
he was in his stocking feet i had
distinctly heard the [ __ ] tramping of a
pair of shoes upon the cabin roof
i had heard them descend the steps
possibly he had paused outside the door
to take them off
when he reached the bed he stood looking
down upon the sleeper
he stooped over her as if to better
catch her breathing
he whispered softly gertie
he paused for a moment as if for an
answer
none came standing up he put his hand as
it seemed to me
into the bosom of his flannel shirt he
took out a leather sheath
from the sheath he drew a knife it was a
long slender
glittering blade quite 12 inches in
length
at no part was it broader than my little
finger
with the empty sheath in his left hand
the knife behind his back and his right
he again leaned over the sleeper again
he softly whispered
gertie again there was no answer
again he stood upright turning his back
towards the bed
so that he looked towards us his face
was not an ugly one
though the expression was somewhat
saturnine
on it at the instant there was a
peculiar look
such a look as i could fancy upon the
face of a jockey
who toward the close of a great race
settles himself in the saddle with a
determination to finish
well the naked blade he placed upon the
table
the empty sheath beside it then he moved
towards us
my first thought was that now at last we
were discovered
but something in the expression of his
features told me that this was not so
he approached us with an indifference
which was amazing
he passed so close to us that we were
conscious of the slight disturbance of
the air
caused by his passage there was a
gladstone bag on a chair within two feet
of us
picking it up he bore it to the table
opening it out he commenced to pack it
all manner of things he placed within it
both masculine and feminine belongings
even the garments which the sleeper had
taken off
and which lay scattered on the chair and
on the floor even her shoes and
stockings
when the bag was filled he took a long
brown ulster
which was thrown over the back of a
chair he stuffed the pockets with odds
and ends
when he had completed his operations the
cabin was stripped of everything
except the actual furniture he satisfied
himself that this was so
by overhauling every nook and corner in
the process
passing and re-passing violet in me with
a perfect unconcern
which was more and more amazing being
apparently at last clear in his mind
upon that point
he put on the ulster and a dark cloth
cap and began to fasten the gladstone
bag
while he was doing so his back being
turned to the bed
without the slightest warning the woman
in the bed sat up
the man's movements had been noiseless
he had made no sound which could have
roused her
possibly some sudden intuition had come
to her in her sleep
however that might be she all at once
was wide awake
she stared round the apartment with
wondering eyes
her glance fell on the man dressed as
for a journey
where are you going the words fell from
her lips as unawares
then some sudden conception of his
purpose seemed to have flown to her
brain
she sprang out of bed with a bound you
shan't go
she screamed she rushed to him he put
his hand on the table
he turned to her something flashed in
the lamplight
it was the knife as she came he plunged
it into her side
right to the hilt for an instant he held
her spitted on the blade
he put his hand to her throat he thrust
her from him
with the other hand he extricated the
blade he let her fall upon
the floor she had uttered a sort of sigh
as the weapon was being driven home
beyond that she had not made a sound
all was still he remained for some
seconds looking down at her as she lay
then he turned away we saw his face
it was if possible paler than before
a smile distorted his lips he stood for
a moment
as if listening then he glanced around
the cabin
as if to make sure that he was
unobserved his black eyes traveled over
our startled features
in evident unconsciousness that we were
there
then he glanced at the blade in his hand
as he did so he perceptibly shuddered
the glittering steel was obscured with
blood
as he perceived that this was so he
gasped
he seemed to realize for the first time
what it was that he had done
taking an envelope from an inner pocket
of his ulster he began to wipe the blood
from off the blade
while doing so his wandering glance fell
upon the woman lying on the floor
some new aspect of the recumbent figure
seemed to strike him with a sudden
horror
he staggered backwards i thought he
would have fallen
he caught at the wall to help him stand
caught at the wall with the hand which
held the blade
at that part of the cabin the wall was
doubly paneled halfway to the roof
between the outer and the inner panel
that was evidently a cavity
because when in his sudden alarm he
clutched at the wall
the blade slipped from his relaxing
grasp and fell between the panels
such was his state of panic that he did
not appear to perceive what had happened
and at that moment a cry rang out upon
the river
possibly it was someone hailing the
keeper of the lock
ahoy the sound seemed to fill him with
unreasoning terror
he rushed to the table he closed the
gladstone with a hurried snap
he caught it up he turned to flee as he
did so
i stepped out of the alcove i advanced
right in front of him i cannot say
whether he saw me
or whether he didn't but he seemed to
see me
he started back a look of the most awful
terror
came on his countenance and at that same
instant the whole scene
vanished i was standing in the cabin of
the water lily
the moon was stealing through the little
narrow casement
violet was creeping to my side she stole
into my arms
i held her to me eric she moaned
for myself i am not ashamed to own that
temporarily i had lost the use of my
tongue
when in a measure the faculty of speech
returned to me
was it a dream i whispered it was a
vision
a vision i shuddered look
as i spoke she turned to look there in
the moonbeams we saw a woman in her
night dress
lying on the cabin floor we saw that she
had golden hair
it seemed to us that she was dead we saw
her but a moment
she was gone it must have been
imagination
we know that these things are not but it
belonged to that order of imagination
which is stranger than reality
my wife looked up at me eric it is a
vision which has been sent to us
in order that we may expose in the light
of day a crime which was hidden in the
night
i said nothing i felt for a box of
matches on the table
i lit a lamp i looked round and round
the cabin
holding the lamp above my head the
better to assist my search
it was with a feeling of the most absurd
relief that i perceived that everything
was unchanged
that so far as i could see there was no
one there but my wife and i
i think violet if you don't mind i'll
have some whiskey
she offered no objection she stood and
watched me as i poured the stuff into a
glass
i am bound to admit that the spirit did
me good
and what i asked do you make of the
performance we have just now witnessed
she was still i took another drink
there can be no doubt that under certain
circumstances
whiskey is a fluid which is not to be
despised
have we both suddenly become insane or
do you attribute it to the cucumber we
ate at lunch
how strange that mr english should have
told us the story only this afternoon
i wish mr inglis had kept the story to
himself entirely
they were the voices which i heard last
night they were the voices mason heard
it was all predestined i understand it
now
i wish that i could say the same i see
it all
she pressed her hands against her brow
her eyes flashed fire
i see why it was sent to us what it is
we have to do
eric we have to find the knife
i began to fear from her frenzied manner
that her brain must in reality be
softening
what knife the knife which he dropped
between the panels
the boat has only been repainted we know
that in all the essentials the self and
the water lily are one in the same
mr inglis said that the weapon which did
the deed was never found
no adequate search was ever made it is
waiting for us where he dropped it
my dear violet don't you think you had
better have a little whiskey it will
calm you
have you a hammer and a chisel what do
you want them for
it was here that he was standing it was
here that he dropped the knife
she had taken up her position against
the wall at the foot of the bed
frankly i did not like her manner at all
it was certainly where
in the latter portion of that nightmare
the fellow had been standing
i will wrench this panel away she
wrapped against a particular panel with
her knuckles
behind it we shall find the knife my
dear violet this houseboat isn't mine
we cannot destroy another man's property
in that wanton fashion
he will hardly accept as an adequate
excuse the fact that at the time we were
suffering from a severe attack of
indigestion
this will do she took a large carving
knife out of the knife basket which was
on the shelf close by her
she thrust the blade between the panel
and the woodwork
it could scarcely have been securely
fastened
in a surprisingly short space of time
she had forced it loose
then grasping it with both her hands she
hauled the panel bodily away
eric it is there something was there
resting on a little ledge which had
checked its fall onto the floor beneath
something which was covered with paint
and dust and cobwebs
and violet all at once grew timid you
take it
i dare not touch the thing it is very
curious
something is there and by george it is a
knife
it was a knife the knife which we had
seen in the vision
the dream the nightmare call it what you
will the something which had seemed so
real
there was no mistaking it tarnished
though it was
the long slender blade which we had seen
the man draw from the leather sheath
stuck to it by what was afterwards shown
to be coagulated blood
was an envelope the envelope which we
had seen the fellow take from his pocket
to wipe off the crimson stain
it had adhered to the blade when the
knife fell
the envelope fell too at least
i murmured as i stared at this grim
relic this is a singular coincidence
the blood upon the blade had dried it
required but little to cause the
envelope to fall away
as a matter of fact while i was still
holding the weapon in my hand it fell to
the floor
i picked it up it was addressed in a
woman's hand
francis joins esquire fairly streetham
i at once recognized the name as that of
a well-known owner of racehorses
and so-called gentlemen rider
not the least singular part of all that
singular story
was that the letter inside that envelope
which was afterwards opened and read by
the proper authorities
was from mr joins his wife it was a
loving tender letter from a wife who was
an invalid abroad
to a husband whom she supposed was
thinking of her at home
mr joins was never arrested and that for
this sufficient reason
that when the agents of the law arrived
at his residence mr joins
was dead he had committed suicide on the
very night on which we saw that
call it vision on board the water lily
i viewed the corpse against my will i
was not called in evidence
had i been i was prepared to swear as
was my wife
that mr joins was the man whom i had
seen in a dream that night
it was shown at the inquest that he had
suffered of late from horrid dreams
that he had scarcely dared to sleep i
wonder if
in that last and most awful of his
dreams he had seen my face
seen it as i saw his
it was afterwards shown from inquiries
which were made
that mr joins and mr bush tenon to the
self
were beyond all doubt one and the same
person
on the singular circumstances which
caused that discovery to be made
i offer no comment
you